the first time we met do you remember it
i don't you were drunk off your ass well
and
and the hug that you like to give all
the guests on this show when you met me
because we met we were meeting for the
first time yeah even though we had been
on best week ever together we filmed on
opposite coasts yes that's right so i
came to a party in new york for the show
and you were already drunk when i got
there yeah and the hug
the hug turned into a lift you lifted me
off the ground and would not put me down
i felt like jennifer gray in dirty
dancing
except i did not have the time of my
life
that's a thing i was like put baby down
pete
pete's got the baby everybody
did i put you in a corner you didn't no
you we were on a corner
we were on a street corner at the time
oh my god outside yeah you were blackout
drunk like the next day i think you know
the next time we saw each other yeah you
were very apologetic yeah that sounds
like me yeah
well sometimes when i'm drinking and i
get uh blackout drunk which hasn't
happened in a while but i get what i
call big boy strength